The robust robotics group
under the leadership
of professors Nick Roy and
Seth Teller at the MIT Computer
Science and Artificial
Intelligence Laboratory
is developing a voice
commandable autonomous
wheelchair.
This video shows a
research prototype
under development since 2005.
The long term goals
of the project
are to develop intelligent
assistant technology that
can work with a
variety of people,
and the wheelchair
is one example
of this kind of technology.
Our target population
consists of people
who have limited physical
mobility and limited
physical control.
By adding a voice commandable
interface and intelligent
autonomy to a
person's wheelchair,
the chair can then
be used by people
who may not have the necessary
level of physical ability
to control the wheelchair
using a standard interface,
such as a joystick.
We are developing a
range of capabilities
from simply augmenting
existing wheelchairs
to developing a fully
autonomous powered wheelchair.
We are collaborating with the
Boston Home, a specialized care
residence for adults with
progressive neurological
diseases.
And working with TBH, we
plan to develop wheelchairs
that can be used by
more TBH residents
without assistance
from a caregiver,
increasing the independence
and quality of life
of the residents.
Our prototype is a commodity
powered wheelchair.
But we have added a number of
components, such as a low power
laser range scanner to
detect obstacles and provide
fine grained position tracking
for autonomous control.
We have added a
microphone to listen
to the wheelchair
user and speakers
to respond using speech.
On this wheelchair, we
have added a computer
for sensory processing and
intelligent decisioning making.
When the wheelchair
does not need
to provide fully autonomous
navigation and control,
we can deploy a small PDA
tablet instead of a full sensor
suite and computer.
The smaller tablet can easily be
added to existing wheelchairs,
but still allows us to
provide a voice interaction
so that the wheelchair can
give information to its user,
for example, about
daily activities.
The tablet also provides
Wi-Fi connectivity
that allows it to
estimate the wheelchair
position at a room
level and the estimated
position to caregivers.
So the nurses can more easily
stay aware of the wheelchair
users health and needs.
The onboard computer or tablet
can process speech and respond
via speech to user queries.
In the future, we plan to use
the tablet as an alternate way
to interact with
wheelchair users
for populations who have
difficulty with speech.
For full autonomous
navigation and control,
the wheelchair can use
a laser range scanner
to detect obstacles and estimate
its position in the map.
This Hokuyo laser
range scanner sends out
a plane of infrared
light, which it
uses to measure the distance
to obstacles around it.
By comparing the positions of
obstacles around the wheelchair
to the positions of
obstacles in a map,
the wheelchair can estimate
its position in a map
as it moves around.
The wheelchair can use
the same laser sensor
to explore new environments
and build new maps.
Even if an object
is not in the map,
the sensor allows the wheelchair
to detect the new obstacle
and replant around it.
The technologies for autonomous
navigation and control
are not new, although, they
have not been widely deployed
on autonomous wheelchairs.
Our project has a number
of innovative aspects
that are designed to make
autonomous navigation
and control more easily
deployed and adopted
by the general public.
For example, we are building
on well-known robot mapping
algorithms that can learn the
floor plan of environments
and developing
algorithms that allow
a wheelchair to learn
new environments
and build maps from a
narrative guided tour.
The wheelchair can
take instructions
from a human caregiver to learn
the names of places in the map.
This natural language
understanding
will make it much
easier for caregivers
to deploy the wheelchair
in new environments
and make it easier for
users to use the wheelchair.
Once the chair understands the
user's desired destination,
it navigates a route through
the previously learned map
to that intended destination.
Go down the hallway past the
door and along the railing,
until you get to
the refrigerator
in the kitchen on your right.
We are also
developing algorithms
that will allow the
robot to be guided
through unfamiliar environments.
For example, the robot
can follow a simple spoken
directions to an unlabeled
location in the map
by reasoning about how
people use everyday objects
as landmarks for navigation.
For a user with
difficulty communicating,
the chair can learn the user's
behavior and mobility patterns
over time in order to
improve ease of use.
For example, when the
user has a daily routine,
the chair can anticipate the
user's desired destinations
and plan routes
there proactively,
reducing the user burden fully
specifying each destination.
As we add more wheelchairs with
knowledge of where they are,
we can give residents
of the Boston Home
the ability to find each other.
The Intelligent
Wheelchair Project.